The hundredth anniversary of the Sykes-Picot
Agreement has highlighted the artificiality
of many of the borders of countries in the
Middle East.
Now some people talk about, with the rise
of the Islamic State, that maybe it's time
to draw new borders.
Well, that's essentially imperialism 2.0,
but even if someone were to do it, would it
really resolve any of the conflicts?
The people in the Middle East don't live in
neat little pockets.
They're all spread about, and so there's no
way to draw the border that simply includes
one group on one side, and the other group
on the other side.
Any resulting state is going to have a minority,
and therefore a potential for conflict.
If we were simply to redraw borders, what
would the second, third, fourth, fifth and
sixth order effects be?
Consider for example the partition of India.
That was supposed to resolve conflict
but if you look at all the displaced people
that came from the partition in 1947
and impose the same definition of refugee
that's used for the Palestinians, there's
over 200 million refugees in South Asia
and the resulting states point nuclear weapons
at each other.
People criticize the borders as being an imperial
legacy, but to redraw the borders—wouldn’t
that just be Imperialism version 2.0?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
and any other questions you’d like us to
answer in 60 seconds.